[Music]
just wanted to say that a lot of
whispers going around but I'm not going
to make an announcement tonight tomorrow
we'll figure it out so someone's getting
chickened get the party started in the
writers room we always called it a
balloon debate which I don't know if you
have that phrase in the US of like
you're in a hot-air balloon and it's
sinking who do you throw out to let
everyone else live there's an element of
that in the middle of the episode I
think the obvious choices
Tom Tom works they don't care of
speaking my qualities no Tom looks
logical
what a waste wasting to be you I'm not
attacking you I'm defending you feel
like that doesn't feel like Tom comes
under the spotlight as a really quite a
compelling candidate to get the shot he
feels unsupported by ship which I guess
snowballs into him revealing of a bunch
of other feelings about the relationship
I'm not a hippie I don't want to do
threesomes if I think about it I think a
lot of the time I'm really pretty
unhappy I think the relationship is
complex and they both get different
things from each other in regard to the
elements of the show it's about that
delicate moment of which you say that's
too much I can't do this anymore
hey Dad hey the earrings you did so well
know you're the face you're across the
cleanup the optics make sense and what's
more I trust you I guess Logan feels the
the Kendall's a good candidate you know
I think he has certain amount of
residual resentment against him because
of what happened in the previous season
Kendall is somebody he can really trust
in a situation like that he needs
someone who's not gonna flip or do
exactly what Kendall bats
the truth is that my father is a
malignant presence a bully and a liar
and he was fully personally aware of
these events for many years and made
efforts to hide and coverup we knew
pretty early on the shape of the season
for Kendall from where he begins which
is in this entirely submissive freely
beaten dog who ends up denouncing his
father it felt like a true shape to us
you know as long as as long as we could
honor all the different stages of that
journey this is the day his reign ends
they're in trouble they've got a
shareholder meeting in a couple of weeks
which is on a knife-edge and is not
going to have been helped by the
revelation by candles Logan was
completely across all the corporate
misdeeds the company the family
relationships are going to be something
of a [ __ ] show so it's either
well-poised or a terrible mess
depending on how you look at it
you
you